depuis 30 ans les clés sousbois
organisent des animations pour le
Téléton et cette année elle a été
choisie par l'Association française
contre la myopathie comme ville ettablee
dans les ivelines une raison pour la
ville de mettre les bouchers doubles on
essaie de faire au maximum pour faire
grimper le le
compteur dans le 36 37 et à savoir que
cette année le Téléton c'estes muscles
son Téléton on a essayé de faire au
mieux pour muscler la cagnotte tombola
défi sain de Noël l'OTO des familles
animation jeux vidéo ou encore vente de
jouets au gymnase thry Gilardi Philippe
Noiret et Guimier le programme était
chargé on a fait une collecte de jouets
notre but c'est de les vendre au Téléton
et après l'argent sera reversé au
Téléton par pour des associations mais
on a vendu beaucoup de choses on a on
était à midi on était à à 50 € on
propose quand même la tombola on a
rajouté cette année une moto avec
possibilité pour les enfants de se faire
prendre en photo sur la moto en
compagnie du Père Noël des activités qui
attirent toujours autant les visiteurs
sensibles à cette cause c'est la
deuxième fois qu'on vient ici au
télétombe pour pour l'activité brick
l'année dernière on avait fait un train
du télétom avec 36 37 c'est super
chouette et puis là on a vu cette année
que c'était à nouveauosé avec mon fils
donc on s dit on va venir et puis là on
va faire un super sapin normalement pour
à la fin de la journée là nous avons un
loto pour apporter un peu d'argent pour
justement refaire recherche
de ces raisons de de besoin de qu' on a
besoin pour ce monde malade à manilamo
le top départ du Téléton a été donné la
semaine dernière on travaille sur ce
Téléton depuis plusieurs mois on a
défini tout un tas d'animations qui ont
démarré il y a une semaine et qui se
termin la semaine prochaine donc le tton
c'est 24 heures sauf à Manil où on est
pendant on est ici pendant 15 jours
connu pour battre des records de Don
lors du Téléton la ville a mis en place
de nombreuses activités le but organiser
un moment festif tout en éveillant les
consciences les gens donnent mais la
formule que nous avons ici c'est surtout
faire une opération de collecte mais de
façon sympathique à savoir certains vont
pouvoir donner mais certains vont
pouvoir consommer et c'est cette
consommation qui va faire permettre de
faire monter
le ce qui est donné par par Man qui est
offert par Manamo à la recherche pétang
tir à l'arc ou encore dégustation de
nombreuses associations ont répondu Pr
pour l'occasion nous faisons donc deux
deux jeux actuels le tir et le point
pour justement essayer de rentrer le
maximum pour la recherche ce qu'on
propose et qui plaît énormément aux
enfants c'est des brochettes de bonbons
il en reste plus qu'une voyez je vous la
montre c'est la dernière on en a fait
plus plus de 200 son toute partie les
enfants se précipitent et puis au fur et
à mesure au début c'était juste les
brochettes et puis au fur et à mesure ch
ch est venu mettre un petit peu sa
petite touche avec ses propres créations
et chacun participe selon ses capacité
cette année plus de 80 millions d'euros
ont été récoltés par le Téléton et dans
les Yvelines le compteur s'élève à plus
de 723000
[Musique]
€